factors that affect acid strength
include bond polarity
bond strength and conjugate base
stability let's think about
a generic acid h a that donates a proton
to
water to form the hydronium ion h3o plus
and the conjugate base to h a which is a
minus
first let's consider the polarity of the
bond between
h and a if a is more electronegative
than
h a withdraws electron density so we
could draw an arrow pointing towards
the a right as the electrons and the
bond between them are pulled
closer to the a as the electronegativity
of a
increases there's an increase in
the polarity of the bond
as the bond polarity increases more
electron density is drawn away
from the h which makes it easier for h a
to donate a proton
therefore in general an increase in the
polarity of the h8 bond
means an increase in the strength of the
acid
next let's think about the factor of
bond strength and let's consider the
strength of the bond between
h and a the weaker the bond the more
easily the proton is donated therefore
in general a decrease in the bond
strength means
an increase in the strength of the acid
the stability of the conjugate base can
also affect the strength of the acid
the more stable the conjugate base the
more likely the acid is to donate a
proton
so if we think about that for h a the
conjugate base
is a minus and the more stable a minus
is the more likely h
a will donate a proton in solution
therefore
in general the more stable the conjugate
base the stronger the acid
so let's go ahead and write here an
increase in the stability of the
conjugate base
means an increase in the strength of the
acid
even though acid strength is usually due
to all three of these factors bond
polarity bond strength and conjugate
base stability
when we look at examples we're only
going to consider one or two factors
that are the main
contributors to acid strength let's look
at the binary acids
from group 7a on the periodic table so
that's hydrofluoric acid hydrochloric
acid hydrobromic acid and hydro iotic
acid
as we go down the group from fluorine to
chlorine to bromine to iodine
there's an increase in the strength of
the acid so out of these four hydro
iotic acid is the strongest
the main factor determining the strength
of the binary acids in group 7a
is bond strength looking up values for
bond enthalpies allows us to figure out
the strengths of these bonds
for example the hf bond has a bond
enthalpy of
kilojoules per mole while the hi bond
has a bond enthalpy of 299 kilojoules
per mole
the lower the value for the bond
enthalpy the easier it is to break the
bond
and because bond enthalpies decrease as
we go down the
group that means there's a decrease in
bond strength
a decrease in bond strength means it's
easier for the acid to donate a proton
therefore we see an increase in the
strength of the acid as we go down the
group
next let's compare the strengths of some
oxyacids
these oxyacids all have the general
formula xoh
where x is a halogen the acidic proton
is the proton that's directly bonded to
the oxygen and if an oxyacid
donates its proton to water that forms
the hydronium ion h3o plus
and the conjugate base to the oxyacid
for these three oxyacids the halogens
are iodine bromine
and chlorine and as we go from iodine to
bromine to chlorine in group 7a
on the periodic table that's an increase
in the
electronegativity so chlorine is the
most electronegative
out of these three halogens and as we go
up the group
in our halogens there's an increase in
the strength of the acid
so hypochlorous acid is the strongest of
the three
the main factor determining the strength
of these oxyacids
is the bond polarity which is affected
by the electronegativity of the halogen
so the polarity of this oxygen hydrogen
bond
is affected by the presence of the
halogen
as the electronegativity of the halogen
increases
the halogen is able to withdraw more
electron density
away from the right side of the molecule
that
increases the polarity of the o h bond
and makes it easier to donate this
proton
therefore as the electronegativity of
the halogen increases
the acidity of the oxyacid increases
this effect of the electronegative atom
increasing the acidity
is often referred to as the inductive
effect
let's compare hypochlorous acid to two
other oxyacids
and notice how i've left the formal
charges off of these acids just so we
can focus
on general structure notice how the
acidic proton
is directly bonded to the oxygen and all
three of these oxyacids
and in all three of these oxyacids the
oxygen is directly bonded to a chlorine
notice what happens to the structure as
we move to the right comparing chloros
acid to hypochlorous acid
chloros acid has an additional oxygen
bonded to the chlorine
and looking at perchloric acid instead
of only one additional oxygen there are
three additional oxygens
so as we move to the right we're
increasing in the number of oxygens
bonded to the chlorine
oxygen is a very electronegative element
so as we move to the right we're
increasing in the number of
electronegative
atoms in the acid and as the number of
electronegative atoms
increases more electron density is
pulled away
from the acidic proton which increases
the polarity of the oxygen hydrogen bond
so bond polarity increases as we move to
the right
which predicts an increase in the
strength of the acid
as we move to the right and that's what
we observe experimentally perchloric
acid is the strongest of the three in
reality all three factors
affect the strength of the acid however
for simplicity's sake we could just say
that increasing bond polarity is the
main factor for the increasing acid
strength in these oxyacids
carboxylic acids are a group of acids
that all contain
a carboxyl group a carboxyl group
consists of carbon
oxygen oxygen and hydrogen so if we look
at acetic acid
i'll circle the carboxyl group on acetic
acid and i can also circle the carboxyl
group
on formic acid the acidic proton and a
carboxylic acid
is the one that's directly bonded to the
oxygen in the carboxyl group
one reason why this proton is acidic is
because of the presence of this oxygen
in the carboxyl group this oxygen
hydrogen bond is already polarized
but the presence of another
electronegative atom
further increases the polarity of the
oxygen hydrogen bond
increasing the bond polarity makes it
more likely to donate the proton
which increases the acidity for
carboxylic acids it's also important to
consider the stability of the conjugate
base
when acetic acid donates its proton it
turns into its conjugate base which is
the acetate anion
notice that the oxygen that used to be
bonded to the proton now has a negative
formal charge on it
there are two possible resonance
structures that you can draw for the
acetate anion
the first is with the negative charge on
this oxygen and then we could draw
another resonance structure with a
negative charge on the other
oxygen in reality neither resonance
structure is a perfect representation of
the acetate anion
and we need to think about a hybrid of
these two resonance structures
in the hybrid the negative charge isn't
on one of the oxygens
that one negative charge is spread out
or delocalized over
two over the two oxygens so it's like
one oxygen has
negative one half and the other oxygen
has negative one-half
this delocalization of the negative
charge stabilizes the conjugate base
and the more stable the conjugate base
the stronger the acid
therefore the stability of the conjugate
base also affects the acidity of the
carboxylic acid
so because carboxylic acids have
conjugate bases that are resonant
stabilized
carboxylic acids like acetic acid and
formic acid are more acidic